we are so excited about this this hour
because guess what we're going to
introduce you to new talent I bet you've
never heard of her Anthony Mason I know
this guy
he's been around old soul
but have you heard of critically
acclaimed singer songwriter Joy olatukun
hey
[Music]
she recently wrapped her first
headlining tour and she's collaborated
with some of the biggest names in
country music including maren Morris and
Chris Stapleton know top liver they
Anthony Mason spoke with her at her
Nashville home Anthony good morning to
you I've been practicing her name all
morning I can't wait to really hear her
it will come easily very soon trust me
good morning Joy a lot of [ __ ] was named
an artist to watch by Amazon NPR and
Spotify last year as new fans latched
onto her hopeful music during the
darkest days of the pandemic
loving is a sweet
[Music]
Symphony
that all of Heaven and her Joy joining
and my heart trembles at the sound
[Music]
Joy a lot of [ __ ] makes music up in her
Nashville attic this is my special place
my favorite feeling in the world is
holding a guitar like it is where I feel
the safest the songs she's written here
and along the road have made their way
onto TV shows like love Island
[Music]
Gray's Anatomy
[Music]
sorry
and This Is Us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and as she's been sharing on social
media
[Music]
a lot of [ __ ] has a new collaboration
[Music]
you have a song with Chris Stapleton
I don't know can we talk about that
you can
my whole family laughs like this it's
really it's like it's it's really
awesome when we're all together in my
younger day
murder of Nigerian immigrants a lot of
[ __ ] was raised in Arizona talking was
really hard for me as a kid I was very
socially anxious music was freeing for a
shy girl who knew early on that she was
queer I grew up in
a conservative town and a religious
family my parents are from a country
where it's illegal to be gay
so as a kid like I knew that as a person
there had to be some morals up until I
was in a place where I could feel safe
and be myself did you know that such a
place existed I did not and that's why I
write so often about hope
everywhere in her music
even on her guitar it says on there keep
hope alive keep hope alive yeah so
that's on there for you yeah you know if
it helps other people that's sick but it
was a good
it's a good reminder that like I really
do do this because I just life is hard
and like music for me has always been
this amazing healing tool and I hope to
do some of that with what I do
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
I mentioned the hardest part about this
was telling your folks
yes I am so proud of my parents
my biggest fear was that my dad and I
would never have a relationship again
and my whole love of like listening to
music comes from him like he's the one
who showed me Tracy Chapman first
[Music]
it was wild to see someone that looks
like me holding a guitar literally
changed the trajectory of my life
telling my parents was really hard at
first it looked like we wouldn't be
close ever again but then I watched as
they asked a lot of hard questions
and stayed and like learned and loved me
and I swear those two people are the
reason I still believe in good in
humanity
[Music]
a lot of [ __ ] who worked for nearly six
years in an Arizona church is still
deeply religious for a time you wanted
to be a pastor amen
faster now in a way you won't get lost
in a way in your shows you are but I
know that hope is something worth
fighting for
impact why did you want to be a pastor
uh to take care of people and to remind
people of what's good in life even
though like the etymology of the word
Pastor pastoral like it's about
shepherding and it's about care and it's
about
guidance and so that is that sounds like
a dope gig
don't let it bring it to you
you talk a lot about mental health in
your show yeah I honestly think that's
why maybe career-wise I'm having the
moment I am especially because a lot of
the fans that I gained I gained during
the pandemic when I think a lot of us
were having a really hard time
[Music]
[Music]
in her Nashville attic the ceiling is
decorated with meaningful images from
Beyonce To The Beatles it's just little
points of inspiration like when I'm
looking for a cool guitar part you know
yeah make eyes with George and be like
help you know Georgia's looking right
back at you yeah
I think that's why I like this poster a
lot because it looks like they're
looking at me when the light is gone
and you're on your own
you've been trying but the fight never
goes away I have such a huge
responsibility as an artist and I take
it so seriously and what do you see that
responsibility as music is the last
Frontier we have left where people don't
immediately argue with each other you
know people just come to shows from all
different walks of life and listen
and for me that that listening is super
super important especially in these
times boy that's the truth
[Music]
you got a problem
to do
[Music]
he's got such a great spirit and she
does an amazing job of putting it in her
music and it's like she said I think
she's found an enormous number of fans
in the pandemic and I think it's because
of what they heard in the music I'm so
fascinated by her because you hear her
voice and her sound and then you see her
face it's not at all what I would expect
that she would be singing the kind of
music that she has in the genre in the
genre that she's in but her voice is so
pure can we get her music yeah
absolutely is there a new is that yeah
she has an album out that song with
Chris Stapleton just came out Sweet
Symphony the duet together is the song
She Wrote and he joined her on
um yeah and she's and she's writing a
new album as well coming oh really like
her Anthony yeah yeah no and you're
going to hear me hearing a lot of her
because as you saw I mean television
shows are picking up her music all over
the place because it you know it works I
saw some I mean something that you said
was powerful when you were talking about
um her being a pastor yes and the
reasons why she wanted to be a pastor
yes and then you added in
in some ways you are yes I thought that
was powerful because you do you feel it
in her shows absolutely there's a
spiritual component to it and she's
trying to lift everybody up yeah I feel
it in her being yeah absolutely I'd
never heard of her before very good
that's what you do Anthony I mean you
introduce yourself there's a lot of
great musicians out there so now I want
to know more about her and we will thank
you very much